yes you just quoted uh william hague i
think if there was normal times we would
see a resignation we'd see cabinet
members encouraging that and the party
to move on but that's not the world that
we face uh this is far from a conclusive
result it's not a defeat but it's not a
a win
so for the moment i accept the
democratic outcome and i encourage all
colleagues to do the same but as you've
been saying 41 is a significant chunk of
mps that now need to be
included in shaping the party's future
the conduct i would say
over the last couple of days shows that
there's a lot of work to be done to
unite the party you know number 10 jacob
rispol tried to spin this all as a
remain
plot based bizarrely on an article that
i actually wrote of trying to improve
the brexit model by daring to suggest
that we join the single market you know
backbenchers need to be able to express
views and deep dives down on those those
issues but this was a almost like a
trumpian attempt to mislead and and
deliberately to distract us it shows a
worrying grasp of the concerns of about
150 colleagues about the direction the
vision of the party so there's a lot of
work to be done to
reshuffle is now required bring in fresh
talent and actually start to focus on
the bigger issues make the cabinet
construct actually work let's do things
that uh appeal to the country not just
to our base more exciting policies and
then uh you know the privatization of
channel four and bringing back imperial
measurements but a real economic
strategy that's actually going to help
tackle the cost of living crisis
does that mean that you're now falling
in step behind the prime minister again
as i say for the moment uh that is what
we're obliged to do because of this vote
and the fact that the prime minister is
determined to stay but as you've been
again alluding to history will repeat
itself following votes of no confidence
unless there's a massive overhaul in the
style and substance of what we actually
do we need to think bigger much much
bigger in the cost of living crisis if
you are generally interested in bringing
down the
the cost of food then let's lean into
ukraine and keep the port of odessa open
there's a gap in the market for
international leadership there we have a
a design for a modular reactor stuck in
number 10 that would help actually make
us uh more security energy security uh
improve our
in independence if you like on energy
security but it's still stuck there and
it needs to be
approved there are so many ways that we
can think bigger picture and at the
moment we're stuck in micro policies
that focus on just appealing to our base
so are you suggesting forgive me uh mr
elwood that this is just a stay of
execution for the prime minister yes
that's exactly where we are we know that
unless we see improvements uh which are
reflected in the polls in the next three
to four months then the party does what
it does it finds way finds ways to then
uh to move on ruthless though that may
be so like i said the ball is now in
number 10's court to improve it
no it has now my support and as i say
other colleagues should support the
prime minister uh as well uh he said he
can turn things around and if he can
then so be it if not then we know where
this goes it leads us to defeat at the
next general election
how long does he have
well that's a good question i think
we're talking a matter of months up to
party conference um and to show that but
it also can be done as i say in who he
brings on board you know who actually is
around the table at cabinet able to
challenge the cab what cabinet is saying
just lost your pictures for a second mr
ellwood but i'm sure that we can still
um hear you we are hearing um uh in the
papers this morning reading in the
papers this morning that seriously
disloyal mps could be suspended in other
words have the whip removed from them
are you anxious that that might happen
to you
well that isn't the way to go forward
that's ignoring the scale of the concern
here two out of every five
mps are concerned about the direction
travel
uh of this party and uh that needs to be
brought on board uh
it shows again i think a lack of
intelligence and understanding if you
like of the genuine concerns that we're
expressing here uh for the betterment of
the party
um we are being told that brexit
legislation tomorrow bringing forward
tax cuts as well perhaps even a snap
election so it does look as though the
number 10 machine has been jolted into
action well i do hope that this entire
experience has you know jolted number 10
into to action and to be more inclusive
uh
there was no caucus no sub tribe there
was no wing of the party that was behind
this concerns about where the party was
going uh what and you know what number
10 was actually doing came from all
callers of the party and the
number 10 prime minister should be aware
of that
would you support a call
for the rules to be changed so that
the backbenchers could have another vote
of confidence in the prime minister
before the year is out some suggestions
that sergey and brady could look at it
being within six months if that's what
the majority of the conservative party
wanted to see happen
i understand that's what the 1922
committee are actually looking at
deliberately for this reason because if
we are now going to have this stay of
execution if we are now going to to
recognize the democratic outcome and
support the prime minister then then
let's give the prime minister time to
improve
but as you're implying uh methods can be
made the system can be adjusted uh to
mean that the current rule of allowing
the prime minister an entire year uh
would be changed
so is that something that you would
support
i i i would i would see us having to go
down that direction and i would support
it if there's a requirement for it to be
introduced but as i say for the moment
uh the demo i support the democratic
outcome of what happened last night and
it's up to number 10 it's up to the
prime minister uh to act on his word to
say he can actually turn this around
turn out prospects in the polls
around as well and so that we have a
chance of winning the general election